التوازن الدقيق الذي يحكم ويربط
هذا الموقع المقدس هو تحت قوة
منتجي وأنا مسلمة المولودين
حصلوا على حق الوصول إلى فيلم في
مجمع الأقصى من قبل أوصياء الموقع
فقط للمسلمين الذين يسمح لهم بالصلاة هنا لفترة
طويلة ولكن
اتفاق الوضع الراهن غير المكتوب الذي
يخبرنا المصلون أنه يتآكل ببطء.يمكن
لغير المسلمين زيارة المجمع فقط
خلال ساعات معينة.
القرآن بصوت أعلى وأعلى
يقدس هذا الجزء العلوي من الجبل من قبل اليهود أيضًا ،
ويطلقون عليه اسم جبل الهيكل ،
تطالب حركة متنامية من المتطرفين اليهود بأداء صلاة هنا
يمكن أن تقلب الوضع الراهن الذي
نشهده على الأقل رجلان يصليان بينما كانت
الشرطة تقف
بجانبنا.  مجموعات صغيرة مثل
هذه من المصلين غير المسلمين الذين يمرون
عبر المجمع حيث يستمر المسلمون
في الصلاة داخل المسجد ، حيث يوجد
الخلاف هنا حيث يكمن
الجدل في أن
الأردن هو الوصي على الأسس ،
لكن هذا الدور أصبح
رمزيًا بشكل متزايد يقول الخبراء لأنه  إن
إسرائيل هي التي تتحكم في عمليات التفتيش الأمنية
عند نقاط الدخول ، وبالتالي
يرى المدير العام للأقصى أن
الزيارات المتزايدة للمتطرفين اليهود
تحت حراسة الشرطة استفزازًا
أرى هذه الزيارات بمثابة هجوم على
موقعنا المقدس ، كما أخبرني أنا وأنا.  حذروا
حكومة إسرائيل من الابتعاد عن
المسجد الأقصى لأن أي انتهاك
هنا يجر المنطقة بأسرها
وهناك استهزاءات على البوابات
مجموعات صغيرة من اليهود المتطرفين قائلين إن
المعبد سيُبنى في إشارة إلى
دعوة حدودية يمينية متطرفة للبناء.
معبد ثالث على الأرض المقدسة
يصر رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو على أنه
ملتزم بالحفاظ على الوضع الراهن ، لكن
في ظل حكومته ،
تتصاعد الأصوات المتطرفة في أقصى اليمين في تاريخ إسرائيل بصوت
أعلى وأقوى ،
كل هذا يجعل
مكانًا مثيرًا للجدل بالفعل أكثر من أي
وقت مضى.  حدث واحد هنا يمكن أن يكون قد
أشعل فتيل دورات مميتة من العنف في جميع
أنحاء المنطقة ،
وينظر العالم العربي إلى الأقصى كرمز سياسي
بالإضافة إلى كونه رمزًا دينيًا ، ويقع
المجمع في قلب
القدس الشرقية التي
يعتبرها معظم المجتمع الدولي  أن تكون
تحت الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ، لكن
إسرائيل تعتبرها جزءًا من عاصمتها الموحدة
العراق منطقة مخصصة للنساء لحضور
صلاة العصر ، يذهب البعض إلى
مسافات كبيرة للوصول إلى هنا عبر
نقاط تفتيش متعددة ، لكنهم يخبروننا أنهم
وجدوا بعض السلام عند وصولهم
[موسيقى]
مرت هذه الصلاة بسلام كما يفعل معظم الناس
ولكن هنا حتى السفينة الحربية الهادئة ليست
ضمانًا